thanks to brilliant dog for sponsoring
this video it's exam season and the very
best of luck to you who are taking exams
now this video is I think gonna be
particularly relevant to you guys and
it's a video I've been meaning to make
for a long time
it's about this two-word phrase that
I've stolen from my dad dad what's that
two word phrase that you uses your
philosophy active serendipity proactive
serendipity is the phrase that
summarizes my philosophy on life for the
past couple of years and I think it's
particularly relevant to those of you
taking exams at the moment but before
explaining what it means let me tell you
a story in December last year YouTube
flew me to New York to take part in the
first global creator camp which meant I
got to meet a bunch of awesome youtubers
including Lucy moon Chris Ramsey and
binging with babish it meant that I got
to see New York for the first time in
the snow and it meant that this I got to
meet Tom Hanks and yes he was incredibly
lovely had a great handshake and was
like everyone's grandpa and it was a
high point of my life so far meeting one
of my favorite actors who's been in some
of my favorite movies of all time so why
did this happen I was selected out of
all the people on this website to go to
New York because of this video well and
this video and these videos and these
videos I've been making videos on
YouTube for a long time since 2010 and
since that first very amateur video I've
got on to make over 300 on this channel
alone that's not even counting the
hundreds I've made for other people and
from a baseline of no video knowledge
whatsoever I've gone on to make videos
which I'm genuinely proud of over the
years and through the grind I gradually
built up an audience and eventually I
had enough of an audience to apply for
YouTube Nextup which I did and from
YouTube Nextup I was selected to travel
to the global creator camp the point is
while I didn't upload
my videos to specifically travel to New
York and meet Tom Hanks one day I
invested a bunch of time and effort into
something trying to make videos that
we're gonna help people and from all
that hard work an opportunity presented
itself even if the opportunity wasn't
exactly the end goal I was striving
towards so what does proactive
serendipity mean then it's putting
yourself in a position where you can be
lucky yes absolutely there are times in
life when you have a definite goal to
work towards like your exams you know
you can be assessed on certain things so
you study those things you sit the paper
and you get a mark but not everything is
in your control proactive serendipity is
the idea that the best you can do in any
situation in life is to work and put
effort in to get yourself in a position
where good things can happen to you so
in the case of an exam that means
opening up the exam paper and finding
questions that you can answer the choice
of questions is completely out of your
control and the best you can do is work
to the point where you're very likely to
get questions that you can answer but it
isn't guaranteed you might open the
paper and get a bunch of questions that
are all in areas you're weakened the
thing is pretty much all situations in
life rely on a little bit of luck and
often that luck is only accessible to
you if you've put in a bunch of time and
effort beforehand in other words people
who get lucky are lucky if and only if
they have put in a bunch of time and
effort before to make that luck
accessible to them so for example people
who get good grades in exams got lucky
that questions that they could answer
came up but they were only able to be
lucky because they put in all that time
beforehand that maximize the chances
that they would get questions they could
answer so a significant part of your
exams success is dependent on luck but
what happens if you plow all of your
effort into exam preparation and you get
unlucky or something goes wrong I
imagine a lot of you watching this video
preparing to sit exams and you're
terrified of the idea of getting a bad
grade in
your exams well you know single back
grade is gonna ruin my life you might be
thinking no it doesn't have to
sure getting a bad grade is incredibly
disheartening it's not what you wanted
but a single failure doesn't mean defeat
for one thing and remember if you put a
bunch of time into preparing for the
exam you put yourself in a position
where good things could happen to you in
the exam but not just the exam let me
give you an example when I was finishing
my undergrad I had the offer to do a PhD
in hand I just needed to get more than a
2:1 overall in my degree which meant
getting more than 50% in my final exams
when it came to the final exams though I
basically had a complete mental
breakdown see my draw my life video for
more details
I completely bombed the exams and ended
up missing my overall to one requirement
by less than a tenth of a percent
my supervisor wasn't allowed to take me
on and give me funding because of my
grade but because of my academic record
up until that point as well as a summer
research project I'd done in their
department the year before they were
able to sort me out with funding with a
different supervisor on a similar topic
at a different University Exeter the
cumulative work I put into my degree as
well as the work I'd done to make myself
known to the department had the angle of
trying to get a PhD placed there and
when that didn't work out the work had
still happened I was still known as a
competent scientist and as a hard worker
and I was still in the position where
good things could happen to me even if
the stuff that happened wasn't quite
what I've intended in the first place
the point is that working towards your
goals doesn't guarantee success sure
sometimes it does and the probability of
success definitely increases the more
work you put in but putting the work in
investing the time in my experience has
a funny way of eventually paying off no
matter what no this isn't karma I don't
believe in that kind of thing I don't
believe that by uploading videos to
YouTube I earned the karmic right to
meet one of the greatest actors of all
time or by working hard
karmak right to a PhD place my
philosophy is simply that you need to
work hard to achieve your goals but in
order to achieve them you often need a
little bit of luck look that's only
accessible to you if you've put the time
in beforehand and if you don't get lucky
despite the amount of work you throw at
something it doesn't mean that that work
was wasted good things can still come of
it so if you're taking exams the very
best of luck to you and definitely work
your absolute hardest in preparation
maximize the chance that things can go
your way in the exam but know that if
things don't go your way it's not the
end of the world your work will still
count for something you just need to be
open to the opportunities that life
presents you with I bombed a bunch of
exams at the worst possible time but
moving to AXT if my PhD was the single
best thing that's ever happened to me
and it wasn't even an option I
considered when applying for phd's I got
really lucky but I was only able to be
really lucky because I'd worked really
hard practice serendipity but it also
needs to be taken into account with
Clark second principle which is handled
screwdriver ring if you're preparing for
exams then one of the best ways you can
do so is to do pass papers from your
exam board but personally I found that
by answering questions on the same
subject matter in different formats in
different environments men I got so much
more out of my revision so as well as
past papers I recommend if you're
preparing for exams test yourself on
brilliant dog brilliant is an
educational website based around science
and maths and they have a quiz feature
where you can jump into practice
questions on a topic of your choice it's
a fantastic way to revise material and
they also have structured courses
ranging from elementary maths and
science to advanced topics like
relativity and neural networks should
you wish to go over your material in
more detail go to brilliant org forward
slash Simon Clark and sign up for this
amazing website for free and in addition
to that the first 200
able to go to that link will get 20% off
their annual premium subscription thank
you so much brilliant for sponsoring
this video and thank you for watching I
apologize that there was something of a
dry spell on this channel for about a
week which apparently is enough for some
of you to think that I retired or died
but rest assured I'm back I basically
had to take some time out to focus on my
thesis Corrections which fingers crossed
at the time of recording are basically
done now and so I'm back focusing on
making content for you guys full-time
incidentally if you're not aware I've
started live streaming on twitch TV /dr
Simon Clarke where if you're preparing
for exams I've been going through pass
papers for physics and maths in an
attempt to sharpen up my somewhat rusty
skills and also show you guys how to
tackle problems and how to make the most
out of revising with past papers
definitely follow me on Twitch if you
haven't already and thank you again for
watching this video do give it a like if
you enjoyed it and share it with people
that you think might enjoy my I don't
want to call it a philosophy but like
view I guess anyway thanks for watching
I'll see you in the next one